THE WHITE HOUSE STILL HAS NOT
OFFERED COMPREHENIVE DETAILS
ABOUT ITS PLAN TO DISTRIBUTE
HALF A BILLION TESTS FOR FREE.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS DR. VIVEK
MURTHY.
HOW MUCH HIGHER DO YOU THINK IT
WILL GO AND WHEN WILL IT PEAK?
>> WELL, JOHN, YOU KNOW, IT IS
TROUBLING TO SEE THESE NUMBERS,
TO SEE HOW HIGH THE CASES ARE
GOING, TO KNOW OUR
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE INCREASED
LIKE THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS THE
CONSEQUENCE OF AN EXTRAORDINARY
TRANSMISSIBLE VARIANT, THE
OMICRON VARIANT.
AS TROUBLING AS THIS IS AND AS
TOUGH AS THE NEXT FEW WEEKS MAY
BE THERE IS SOMETHING IMPORTANT
WE HAVE BEEN LEARNING DURING
THIS EXPERIENCE AND THAT IS THAT
OUR VACCINES, ESPECIALLY WHEN
COMBINED WITH BOOSTERS, HAVE
REMAINED EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE AT
KEEPING PEOPLE OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL AND IT IS SAVING THEIR
LIVES.
IT IS WHY WE HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED AND BOOSTED.
WHEN I TALK TO DOCTORS IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM AND COLLEAGUES IN
HOSPITALS AROUND THE COUNTRY,
THEY CONTINUE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE PEOPLE THEY ARE SEEING WHO
ARE HOSPITALIZE READY PRIMARILY
THOSE WHO ARE NOT VACCINATED.
SO, REMEMBER, THESE VACCINES
WORK, THOSE BOOSTERS ARE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER BEFORE.
THERE IS ANOTHER GLIMMER OF HOPE
HERE, AS WE LOOK AT DATA FROM
SOUTH AFRICA AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM, WE'RE SEEING INCREASING
SIGNS THAT THE SEVERITY TO AN
INDIVIDUAL OF OMICRON COMPARED
TO PRIOR VARIANTS MAY IN FACT BE
LOWER.
WE STILL ARE AT A POPULATION
LEVEL, WE HAVE A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE OF SO MANY PEOPLE BEING
INFECTED.
BUT WE'RE ALSO SEEING A SHARP
RISE AND NOW A DROPOFF IN THOSE
COUNTRIES.
HOPEFULLY THAT WILL BE OUR CASE
AS WELL.
>> WHEN?
WHEN DO YOU THINK THAT WILL DROP
OFF IN THE U.S.?
>> SO THAT IS DIFFICULT TO
PREDICT.
WE HAVE SEEN THE RISE AND -- TO
THE PEAK HAS BEEN A COUPLE OF
WEEKS OR SEVERAL WEEKS, I SHOULD
SAY, IN SOUTH AFRICA AND THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
WE'RE ALWAYS CAUTIOUS ABOUT
PREDICTING WHAT WE WILL
EXPERIENCE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
COVID MADE MANY PREDICTION
WRONG.
WHAT WE CAN DO THOUGH IS FOCUS
ON TAKING THE MITIGATION
MEASURES AND WEARING OUR MASKS,
WHICH WE KNOW HELP REDUCE
SPREAD, GETTING VACCINATED AND
BOOSTED AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
ENSURING THAT IN SETTINGS LIKE
SCHOOLS, WE'RE USING TESTING TO
HELP REDUCE RISK.
>> OKAY, TESTING.
THE SURGEON GENERAL OF FLORIDA
NOW SUGGESTS LIMITING TESTS TO
HIGH VALUE SUBJECTS, TO HIGH
VALUE TESTING.
DON'T TEST EVERYONE NECESSARILY,
TEST PEOPLE WHO MAYBE ARE
SYMPTOMATIC OR GREATER RISK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK WE ACTUALLY
STUDIED TESTING A LOT OVER
RECENT MONTHS AND WE KNOW WHERE
IT IS USEFUL.
TAKE SCHOOLS.
WE KNOW THAT USING TESTING,
SURVEILLANCE TESTING IN SCHOOLS
CAN BE A VERY IMPORTANT WAY TO
HELP REDUCE RISK TO OUR
TEACHERS, AND TO OUR STUDENTS.
WE KNOW THAT TESTS TO STAY IS AN
IMPORTANT POLICY THAT CAN BE
USED.
WHEN WE'RE USING -- MAKING
DECISIONS, POLICY DECISIONS ON
WHERE TO USE TESTING, IT IS
IMPORTANT THESE ARE DRIVEN BY
THE EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
ASYMPTOMATIC CAN ALSO TEST
POSITIVE.
SO LIMITING TESTING TO JUST
THOSE WHO ARE SYMPTOMATIC IS NOT
ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
SCIENCE WE HAVE LEARNED OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
>> DO YOU THINK TESTING IS
ESSENTIAL TO KEEP SCHOOLS OPEN?
>> I THINK IT IS ONE OF SEVERAL
LAYERS THAT CAN HELP KEEP STOOLS
OPEN.
WE LEARNED OF THE FALLEN FACT,
WE KEPT 95% OF KIDS BACK IN
SCHOOL IN PERSON, THAT LAYERS
WORK, AND LAYERS INCLUDE
SURVEILLANCE TESTING AND
UNIVERSAL MASK, USING THE $10
BILLION PROVIDED IN THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN TO IMPROVE
VENTILATION AND WE KNOW THAT
GETTING OUR KIDS VACCINATED
MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE AS WELL.
THAT'S WHY YOU TALK TO
PEDIATRICIANS AROUND THE
COUNTRY, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
KIDS WHO ARE BEING HOSPITALIZED
NOW ARE THOSE WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED.
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE SCHOOL-AGED
CHILDREN.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A POINT,
IN CHICAGO, THEY HOLD A VOTE
TODAY, THE TEACHERS, TO
BASICALLY NOT GO IN AND TEACH
NOW.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A
SCIENTIFIC JUSTIFICATION TO NOT
HAVE SCHOOLS OPEN AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, JOHN, LOOK, I KNOW
THESE ARE TOUGH, TOUGH TIMES FOR
PARENTS AND FOR EDUCATORS.
AS YOU MENTIONED, I'M A DAD OF
TWO KIDS.
ONE OF THEM IS OLD ENOUGH TO BE
VACCINATED.
MY SON IS 5 AND NOW FULLY
BUT MY DAUGHTER IS UNDER 5 AND
SHE IS NOT ELIGIBLE YET FOR A
VACCINE.
MY WIFE AND I ARE PLANNING TO
SEND HER TO SCHOOL.
OUR SCHOOL HAS THE APPROPRIATE
LAYERS OF PRECAUTION.
IT IS A PUBLIC SCHOOL, IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND WE FEEL
PROUD OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS, SCHOOLS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE SOME
CHALLENGING DECISIONS HERE.
WE HOPE THAT THEY USE THE
MITIGATION MEASURES THAT WE KNOW
WORK TO KEEP OUR KIDS SAFE.
BUT I RECOGNIZE IN SOME CASES
SCHOOLS MAY HAVE TO MAKE
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY DECISIONS IF
THEY HAVE LARGE NUMBER OF STAFF,
FOR EXAMPLE, WHO ARE OUT SICK OR
FEEL THEY CAN'T TAKE THE
MEASURES.
THE GOAL IS, KEEP OUR KIDS IN
SCHOOL, THAT IS OUR TOP
PRIORITY.
WE JUST NEED TO DO IT SAFELY.
OUR MITIGATION MEASURES CAN HELP
US DO THAT.
>> THE CDC CHANGED ITS GUIDANCE
FOR ISOLATION PERIOD AFTER YOU
TEST POSITIVE FROM TEN DAYS TO
FIVE DAYS.
AND THERE IS NO TESTING
REQUIREMENT TO GET OUT OF IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TEST NEGATIVE
TO GO BACK AND JOIN THE
WORKFORCE.
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SAID IT WAS
BEING DISCUSSED TO NOW ADD A
TESTING REQUIREMENT.
WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THAT?
>> WELL, AS YOU MENTIONED,
GUIDANCE ON SHORTENING THE
ISOLATION PERIOD WAS ONE THAT
THE CDC ISSUED LAST WEEK.
THEY HAVE RECEIVED FEEDBACK AND
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ROLE OF
TESTING, IN SHORTENING THAT
QUARANTINE PERIOD AND THEY'RE
WORKING ON ISSUING A
CLARIFICATION ON THAT.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT ANY DAY NOW.
>> WHAT KIND OF CLARIFICATION,
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> WELL, THEY'RE GOING TO SPEAK
TO THE ROLE THAT TESTING CAN
PLAY IN A SITUATION LIKE
REDUCING ISOLATION.
WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO SAY MORE BROADLY,
IS RECOGNIZE AND INCORPORATE
BOTH THE EVOLVING SCIENCE ON
OMICRON AND ON PRIOR VARIANTS IN
TERMS OF HOW LONG SOMEBODY
REMAINS CONTAGIOUS, WITH THE
CRITICAL NEED TO MAINTAIN
ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
THAT MEANS MAKING SURE PEOPLE
CAN SEE A DOCTOR, IF THEY'RE
SICK, THAT THERE IS A FIRE
PERSON TO SHOW UP IF THEIR HOUSE
IS ON FIRE, AND THAT MEANS WE
HAVE TO BALANCE THOSE.
THOSE ARE ALL PART OF PUBLIC
SAFETY.
CLARIFICATION WILL COME OUT IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
>> WHAT IS THE SCIENCE, THOUGH,
BEHIND THE DECISION NOT TO
INITIALLY REQUIRE A NEGATIVE
TEST?
IS THERE SCIENCE THAT SAYS A
NEGATIVE TEST DOESN'T MATTER?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I BELIEVE IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SCIENCE AND
AGAIN THE CDC IS GOING TO
COMMENT ON THAT SCIENCE.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR THEM.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN THIS THERE IS
UTILITY FOR ANTIGEN TESTS IN A
VARIETY OF SITUATIONS.
WE RECOMMENDED THEM TO PEOPLE
BEFORE THEY GET TOGETHER AT
HOLIDAY GATHERINGS, WE HAVE SEEN
MANY SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES USE
THEM TO SCREEN PEOPLE OUT.
SO I BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE
A ROLE FOR ANTIGEN TESTING HERE
TO HELP REDUCE RISK AS WELL.
>> I GOT TO LET YOU GO.
THE RECORD PEDIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS AT THIS POINT,
PART OF THIS IS JUST THIS VIRUS
IS EVERYWHERE AT THIS POINT AND
EVERYONE IS GETTING IT.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT
PARTICULARLY MAKES CHILDREN MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO OMICRON?
>> IT IS A REALLY GOOD QUESTION,
JOHN.
IT IS ONE WE HAVE BEEN SPEAKING
NOT ONLY INTERNALLY ABOUT, BUT
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AROUND THE
WORLD.
UNDERSTAND IS THERE SOMETHING
THEY'RE SEEING IN THEIR DATA
THAT MAKES THEM WORRY IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT CHILDREN?
I WOULD SAY AT THIS POINT IT IS
STILL NOT CLEAR THAT KIDS ARE
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO OMICRON
COMPARED TO ADULTS.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT IN MANY
PARTS OF THE WORLD, THAT KIDS
HAVE HAD A LOWER VACCINATION
RATE.
WHICH MAY BE ONE OF THE
OPERATIVE ELEMENTS HERE THAT IS
DRIVING KIDS TO NOT ONLY GET
SICK, BUT TO HAVE SOME KIDS END
UP IN THE HOSPITAL.
IT IS WHY WE HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO HERE TO GET MORE CHILDREN
VACCINATED.
WE HAVE MORE THAN 200 MILLION
PEOPLE VACCINATED IN OUR
COUNTRY, MILLIONS WHO ARE
BOOSTED.
BUT KIDS WHO HAVEN'T HAD
VACCINES AUTHORIZED LATER FOR
THEM BECAUSE THE STUDIES TOOK
LONGER TO DO AND THAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO DO THOROUGHLY, BUT
NOW WE HAVE TO PUT THE FOOT ON
THE ACCELERATO